Let's look at the answer
to our inclusion quiz.
If the two caches do
maintain inclusion property,
the block that was in L1
still is in L2 as well.
So when we want to write it back,
it will be a level two hit and
it cannot be a level two miss
because inclusion guarantees that,
that block still exists in L2.
After we do the write back, we can
try to bring the new block into L1.
And that may replace this
block from both L1 and L2.
But until it's written back,
it's a block that exists in L1.
So it also is in L2.
Thus the write back is a hit.
In contrast, if we make no
attempt to maintain inclusion
when a dirty block is replaced
from the level one cache.
That block may or may not be in
the level two cache as well.
So we may have a write back
be a level two right hit or
if the block is not in L2
anymore it will be a miss.
So write back handling
becomes slightly easier if
you do maintain the inclusion property.